freshman year at college I had a pretty
rowdy group of friends on Sundays we see
go to this one friend's house outside of
the city we always have a bonfire and we
drink a lot it was a porta potty on the
land and we decided that it'd be funny
to put it on the fire
all of us like we get the porter potty
we put it on top of the fire went up and
a wonderful blaze of glory
I've never opening up the door and like
seemed like the flame come through the
toilet so we went back to the house and
my friend who was the owner of the
lantern porta potti asked who would put
it on the fire and we all played stupid
he was like if you guys don't replace it
I'm gonna whip your ass what PRS would
be our ass and emphasis on my ass
because like I was like mainly
responsible so all week in between
classes we drove in that part of the
city looking for porta-potties I went to
like construction sites and I went to
like apartment complexes finally found
one I got two of my friends and one of
them had a truck uh you know still this
Florida party I couldn't lift it cuz
like I'm a little so we had to call more
friends but like I was in the middle and
so we were lifting it up and peeing the
poo fell all over me he from like my
waist down I'm like covered and it was
so gross I smelled so bad I hated it so
much in spite of that we got it on the
truck and it laid back those things are
so tall so we got on the truck and we
were as we were driving back my friend
almost wanted to give up he's like about
to like throw up but I was like just
keep driving like we have to get there
so we get back to my friend's house he
has a party going on which is what he
needed the porta potti for to begin with
so there's a whole bunch of people there
they see us with like this ridiculous
porta potty in the back of a truck and
they all start cheering for us went home
took a shower got back and finished
tonight party tide took about 40 hours
they went to the party I went back home
and I took a shower and I went partied